[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la crise au yémen est la pire crise
humanitaire au monde
[Musique]
on
le synaps online the matter barbara
match aller au gré des kabyles
[Applaudissements]
se servant d'une millionnaire foule
il a mis la main sur les lieux donald et
martin st-louis mercredi walla walla ou
bas à la tyrannie l'iphone
[Musique]
on a une des retraits salle au yémen il
n'y a pas de contrôle international sur
cette guerre
ça aboutit à la terreur ce aboutir
destruction des hôpitaux des écoles
[Musique]
système sanitaire est complètement au
point mort la situation est vraiment
vraiment très très alarmante ici
[Musique]
arabie saoudite contrôler toute entrée
dans les mêmes c'est un pays qui est
cadenassée c'est très difficile de s'y
rendre d'obtenir des visas de travail et
d'enquêtés et c'est une vraie volonté
d'empêcher que de l'information sorte de
ce pays il ya beaucoup de journalistes
qui ont été tués beaucoup de
journalistes emprisonnés pour un
journaliste occidental la mission est
quasiment impossible
c'est un pays dangereux oui les
journalistes eux risquent leur peau
quand ils vont l'avoir
c'est évident c'est nécessaire en même
temps
salut tout le monde je suis pour brut au
yémen j'ai réussi à pénétrer dans le
pays le plus inaccessible au monde
particulièrement pour les reporters
occidentaux et je suis venu pour vous
expliquer comment la guerre impact le
quotidien des civils mais aussi pour
vous montrer leurs conditions de vie
[Musique]
là on avec janssen il a 22 ans il vivait
à sanaa et il a été victime d'une balle
perdue
laval est rentré par ici elle ressentie
par là donc ils se retrouvent avec tout
ce côté là paralysé là il a une demi
paralysie et son oeil aussi voit plus
avec on peut dire que c'est un miraculé
parce que pour que la balle ait traversé
son cerveau qui soit encore vivant on
peut dire que c'était pas son heure sur
place pour aller à la rencontre des
yéménites
j'ai rejoint un humanitaire français qui
travaillent depuis plus de 15 ans dans
des zones de conflit avec différentes
ong et qui a l'habitude de venir en aide
aux déplacés
un garçon c'est un petit garçon sa peau
au dg commence déjà à être attaqué tu
vois commence à avoir des signes de
problèmes de peau il faut savoir que si
un enfant est infecté par des matières
fécales
il peut se déshydrater très rapidement
par une gastro-entérite en l'espace de
vingt-quatre même pas 24 heures il peut
il peut décéder
donc le principal problème c'est surtout
l'eau et l'hygiène pour ces enfants là
ici la plupart des habitations sont
faites avec des morceaux de bois ou ce
sont des petites tentes
est-ce qu'il faut bien réaliser c'est
que ce sont des gens qui ont fui des
zones de combat où il avait des maisons
en dur dans lesquelles ils habitaient
depuis plusieurs années voire des
dizaines d'années donc ils ont vraiment
tout perdu je vous faire visiter une
maison pour vous puissiez voir les
conditions dans lesquelles vivent la
majorité des personnes déplacées
williams n ya pas d'électricité il n'y a
pas d'eau il n'y a pas de toilettes les
conditions de vie sont vraiment très
près qu'à celles lavera les cons c'est
là où les enfants dorment avec la
chaleur qu'il fait c'est complètement
étouffant donc ils peuvent pas rester à
l'intérieur comme vous voyez c'est
évident
une grande partie des réfugiés vivent
dans des conditions vraiment
insupportable ici c'est la chambre des
parents
voilà le lit pouvait voir l'intimité et
la qualité de l'endroit où ils n'ont
même pas la place pour se lever
il faut savoir qu'il ya plus de 3
millions de yéménites qui ont été
déplacés qui vivent dans des conditions
aussi précaires que celle ci et c'est
bien pour cette raison que on dit que la
crise au yémen est la pire crise
humanitaire en cours
[Musique]
poule b wallabies à rennes pour
comprendre comment ces civils se sont
retrouvés dans ce camp de déplacés
il faut je vous explique la guerre qui
se déroule actuellement au yémen
je vous préviens c'est pas simple faut
s'accrocher un peu les causes du conflit
yep ministre vienne à la révolution de
2011 parce que comme dans d'autres pays
arabes il ya eu aussi une révolution en
2011 pour mettre fin à l' autoritarisme
de l'ex président ali abdallah saleh
requis à gouverner le yémen
de 1978 à fin 2011 cet ex président n'a
pas supporté le fait que son vice
président abd rabbo mansour a indiqué
aujourd'hui le président humaines lui
succède et donc il s'est allié à ses
anciens ennemis l'air aussi pour prendre
le pouvoir dès septembre 2014 avec la
prise de sanaa la capitale du yémen
il ya la guerre urbaine parce que les
saoudiens ont constitué une coalition
avec les émirats arabes unis et toute
une série de pays arabes sunnites
face à une rébellion qui est chiite et
soutenue par l'iran parce que l'iran
c'est le grand fantasme des saoudiens il
en a une tous le terrible l'arabie
saoudite considèrent le yémen comme son
arrière-cour tout ce qui se passe au
yémen
seul et j'emmerde la situation au yémen
aujourd'hui est très complexe bien sûr
puisqu'on a au nord un pouvoir rebelles
le pouvoir des rossi qui tient fermement
ces régions du nord et puis on a un
pouvoir légitime qu'ils résident
principalement à ryad dans la capitale
saoudienne et qui ne peut exercer ses
prérogatives dans les régions du yémen
qu'il est censé contrôler et puis on a
un autre force politique extrêmement
puissante qui est représenté par le
mouvement séparatiste au sud qui
essayent d'étendre son influence dans
les gouvernorats du sud avec l'aide des
émirats arabes unis qui ont soutenu et
créer des milices séparatistes au sud
l'une des conséquences dramatiques de
cette guerre pour les civils c'est une
énorme pénurie alimentaire dans tout le
pays et ça concerne environ 80% de la
population du yémen
pour vous et un aperçu un petit peu de
l'urgence alimentaire dans ce camp par
exemple des enfants que vous avez
derrière et mangent exclusivement de ça
c'est du pain qui est que lui dans de
l'huile et comme vous pouvez voir lui il
est carrément noir une fois que lui lait
frelaté
bien entendu les enfants tombent malades
il n'y a pas de structures médicales
pour les prendre en charge
il n'y a pas de nutriments suffisant
pour pouvoir participer à la croissance
des enfants
sur l'ensemble du territoire du yémen la
situation alimentaire est vraiment
catastrophique et il faut vraiment se
mobiliser pour leur apporter un soutien
d'urgence
là on a eu de la chance d'arriver au
moment où une ong est passé en même
temps que louait leur a donné un sac de
riz comme celui là et c'est l'essentiel
de l'aide qu'ils reçoivent y reçoivent
ni légumes ni viande ni quoi que ce soit
en général c'est simplement du riz c'est
ça que lui permet de nourrir ses enfants
pendant les dix jours
mais ya pas de cycle de distribution en
régulier donc c'est vraiment très très
très aléatoire je vais rentrer dans un
hôpital pédiatrique de maareb pour vous
montrer comment la pénurie alimentaire
et les blocus sur la nourriture impacte
les enfants
donc là je suis avec la petite rama qui
à seulement sept mois elle peser moins
de 4 kg quand elle est arrivée dans
l'hôpital alors qu'elle devrait en faire
au moins 7
elle souffre de malnutrition et c'est
parce qu'elle arrive de sanaa la
capitale du yémen qui est sous contrôle
outil où le prix des denrées
alimentaires est très élevé les médecins
lui donnent du lait thérapeutique et ses
jours ne sont pas en danger
la guerre a entraîné l'effondrement
économique du pays le prix des denrées
alimentaires a augmenté de 150% celui du
carburant de près de 200% et cette
explosion des prix a eu un impact très
négatif dans le domaine des transports
de la santé sur l'agriculture mais aussi
sur l'électricité et l'eau en dehors de
la question de la nourriture il ya aussi
le problème de l'eau vous pouvez voir
que la ils ont magazine des bidons mais
ça c'est de l'eau salée qui sort d'un
puits qui à peu près à deux kilomètres
d'ici donc c'est des enfants
principalement qui vont le chercher qui
viennent avec des bidons sous le soleil
et pour ce qui est de l'eau potable
c'est une demi journée de marche les
enfants font une demi journée de marche
pour aller chercher de l'eau potable et
revenir donc vous pouvez voir qu'à tous
les niveaux a vraiment tout à faire en
l'onu estime que 16 millions de
yéménites n'ont pas accès à l'eau
potable
cette situation a entraîné une terrible
épidémie de choléra est depuis début
2016 au moins deux mille neuf cents
personnes sont mortes à cause de la
maladie et dans le pays 1,1 million de
personnes ont été infectées par le
choléra
ce qui m'a particulièrement touché dans
la situation de ces trois millions de
déplacés c'est le sort des enfants pour
la plupart ils n'ont pas école et ne
font pas grand chose de leur journée il
ya plus de 3500 enfants qui ont besoin
d'éducation et il ya seulement 4 100
places disponibles et les écoles c'est
ce que vous voyez derrière moi c'est de
simples tentes avec quelques tables et
quelques chaises c'est très important de
que malgré la guerre on puisse maintenir
un système éducatif parce que c'est
justement par l'éducation que la
population va pouvoir reprendre le
dessus c'est ce qui va permettre aux
enfants de voir d'autres horizons et
notamment de sortir de ce cycle de
violence qui s'engage pas dans les
milices ou dans les différentes factions
qui sont actuellement en guerre quoi
donc pouvoir leur donner des
perspectives d'avenir autre que
combattre tuer et mourir pour des
raisons qu'ils y ont eux mêmes
la sorbonne l'afp un avocat promis à
montano seul ministre de l'habitat
quant aux gens que nous cherchons
toujours tendrement ses lacs ses vestes
y croire victor hectares de riz dans
notre dame crie mois et dame chantal
moreau namphy when you're genia
cherchons d'arbustes la crise l'accord
le camp des rouges barres comme gramacho
fois glamour acteur actif la joue de la
dram g aux jo 2004 a fait un voyage il
manque tout comme adam azhar à gaza vers
calais les rafales madani sy mieux nous
au dalaï lama et âme à la charge est
largement meilleur benzema pas de ma
part mina bazaar elle mange ou des aléas
probablement tout cas le café riche et
de lisa à g et phasage il admis charles
[Musique]
la guerre au yémen
ça nous concerne nous aussi les français
la france vend des armes à des pays qui
font la guerre sur place l'arabie
saoudite et les émirats rabin pourtant
le président de la république et le
gouvernement ont toujours nié que du
matériel de guerre français aient pu
être utilisés dans le conflit au yémen
nous sommes complètement dans une fidèle
dans les ventes d'armes vont traiter du
commerce des armes que nous respectons
totalement une respectant aussi la
procédure européenne qui nécessitent des
contrôles nécessaires mais en ce qui
concerne la guerre du yémen l'action de
l'arabie séoudite s'effectue
essentiellement par voie aérienne et
nous fournissons rien à l'armée de l'air
saoudienne
je n'ai pas connaissance du fait que des
armes soient utilisées directement dans
ce conflit il y a un certain nombre
d'armes qui sont à ma connaissance
oui vous avez la connaissance à ma
connaissance c'est que je n'ai pas
connaissance et mots ont un sens la
france a une politique extrêmement
rigoureuses en la matière avec une
commission interministérielle justement
de contrôle des armements qui est
présidé par le premier ministre et qui
est justement très scrupuleux sur ce
point et nous ne faisons pas partie des
fournisseurs sur ces matières la de
l'arabie saoudite sur justement ce
conflit sauf que depuis le média en
ligne disclose a révélé un document
confidentiel remis au président de la
république et aux principaux membres du
gouvernement le 3 octobre 2018 donc
avant les déclarations qu'on vient
d'entendre et cette note classée secret
défense prouve qu'une partie de
l'armement français est bien utilisé
dans la guerre au yémen
il y a donc de fortes probabilités pour
que des armes françaises est servi à
tuer des civils c'est un scandale d'état
parce que ces documents classés
confidentiel défense
dévoilé en fait les mensonges du
gouvernement français qui est scandaleux
ce que le président de la république
manque aussi effrontément il avait
connaissance que les armes françaises
étaient utilisés au yémen contre des
civils on a vraiment un gouvernement qui
couvre une guerre sale
au yémen la france fait d'abord a du mal
à reconnaître que ces armes qui sont qui
sont vendus
en arabie saoudite aux émirats sont
utilisés au yémen de manière offensive
évidemment elles peuvent être utilisées
pour tuer des civils
il fait de bombardements indiscriminés
la france est mêlé à une guerre
inadmissible les saoudiens les émirats
arabes unis sont bien incapables de
mener cette guerre
s'il n'ya pas le renseignement américain
le renseignement français et le matériel
américain et le matériel français
c'est une co belligérance c'est à dire
la forme la plus grave de guerre
pratiqué par intermédiaire moralement
politiquement c'est indéfendable pour
avoir révélé cette note classée secret
défense
les journalistes de disclose ont été
convoqués par les services de
renseignement français
on a été auditionné par la jeci c'est un
service de renseignement intérieur qui
s'occupent généralement des affaires de
terrorisme
on est sous enquête pour avoir compromis
le secret de la défense nationale
ça veut dire qu'on aurait porté atteinte
aux intérêts supérieurs de la nation en
dévoilant ces informations d'intérêt
public
donc on utilise le secret défense pour
poursuivre les journalistes qui à chaque
fois il ya une chronique sur nos murs on
rêve nous confidentiel défense ne pas
être respectueux c'est une façon de
cacher les choses au mieux cacher quand
tu dis aux chefs défense comme tu me
réponds pas aujourd'hui le gouvernement
français l'état français estime que le
commerce des armes avec l'arabie saudite
est plus important que les vies de
milliers de civils au yémen
[Musique]
il est très peu d'informations qui
sortent du yémen c'est donc très
difficile d'avoir un bilan exact du
nombre de morts et de blessés là je suis
dans un ancien centre de formation qui a
été réquisitionné par les autorités pour
devenir un hôpital de campagne où il ya
des centaines de blessés qui sont soit
amputé soit dans un état végétatif dans
le coma parce qu'ils ont été blessés au
front
m
[Musique]
certains blessés qui dorment parfois
entretenu pour vous dire à quel point il
ya très peu d'espacé ici et à quel point
ils sont sûrs nom pareil dans cette
pièce elle doit faire à peine huit
mètres carrés il ya cinq patients qui
donne qui vivent ici
la plupart ont été blessées par des
éclats d'obus des balles ou des mines ya
pas de lits médicalisés n'y a pas de
matériel orthopédique un grand manque de
personnel un grand manque d'hygiène
c'est à dire des risques d'infection
donc vraiment vraiment la situation est
vraiment vraiment très très alarmante
ici
[Musique]
à l'avant le leader n'a lancé le courant
de traction arrière directement selon
koon à l'énergie solaire à la menace ne
tourne pas fait l'annoncé le cours est
la diagonale vers le top 10 vous pouvez
voir l'état du matériel et c'est
représentatif de tours est ce fauteuil
là n'est plus utilisable
la plupart en fait ils sont abîmés à ce
niveau là au niveau des ronds c'est pas
du tout fonctionnel et il ya des salles
remplies de matériel cassé ils ont
aucune réserve
et il ya plus de 800 personnes amputées
ou dans l'incapacité de se déplacer de
personnes en situation de handicap très
lourd
ce système sanitaire est complètement au
point mort donc si ce n'est pas par
l'aide humanitaire ces gens là ne
recevront aucune aide
ce conflit n'a plus aucun sens en fait
il est difficile aujourd'hui d'être
optimiste puisque on voit que celui
d'été yéménite est menacé l'état de
belligérance et continue toujours au
détriment évidemment de la population
civile qui souffre de plus en plus et on
a pas les skiffs d'une solution qui
émerge de ce qui est important
aujourd'hui c'est le véhicule et cette
information de la partager de partager
le plus possible l'information qui
tourne autour du yémen il faut que la
question des ventes d'armes au yémen
continuent d'être au coeur de
l'actualité pour qu'on puisse exercer
notre rôle de citoyens de contre-pouvoir
le yémen pire catastrophe humanitaire au
monde
ça commence à toucher la société civile
en france en mai dernier des dockers du
port du havre
soutenu par des ong ont refusé
d'accueillir un navire qui devait
charger des armes à destination des pays
du golfe
justement pour éviter qu'elles tuent des
civils yéménites les chaudrons que on
passe à un stade supérieur c'est-à-dire
mot données qui est des manifs et
sociaux publics parce que j'ai connu les
manifestations contre la guerre
d'algérie contre la guerre d'indochine
contre un lien les jeunes hommes
et depuis enfin il a dit il
le mistral et grenat n'atteint sa
maturité
[Musique]
si ce reportage vous a intéressé
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à achêne de
brut pour ne pas rater le prochain
documentaire a très vite